jeudi prochain s’annonce comme un jeudi
noir dans la rue est-ce que vous
craignez que la France soit bloquée je
pense que c'est c'est une crainte que
nous avons tous que nous partageons tous
j'allais dire de droit de gauche monde
économique monde civil monde politique
c'est le blocage de la rue je pense
qu'on sort de trois années horribles
entre covid crise sanitaire
crise sociale etc enfin je pense qu'on
et puis anxiété dû aussi au contexte
international etc je pense que nous
redoutons effectivement à blocage du
pays ça ne serait pas responsable
globalement pour quelques travailleurs
que ce soit quelques salariés que ce
soit j'entends des discriminations
salariés modestes cadre etc je pense que
notre pays dans une situation difficile
qu'elle est dans une situation sensible
au niveau économique par la crise
énergétique je crois qu'il faut être
responsable et j'ai presque de la peine
de voir Laurent Berger dans des postures
syndicales dur alors qu'on est
d'habitude dans un dialogue avec lui
[Musique]